[Applaudissements]
oui bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir t on
ça m'a tellement y en aura une surprise
pour vous il ya quelqu'un on va faire
les tweets de haters et à quelqu'un qui
est venu expressément pour vous ce soir
mais non vous verrez elton john est très
bon bailly s'échanger la veste et mieux
très bien sûr tous en forme et bien
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça c'est
qu'elle est quel est le but est bon on
va revenir sur plein de choses dans ce
second numéro du média immédiat c'est
quoi c'est simple c'est plus qui a fait
lecture dans les médias que ça traité
dans l'immédiat ne valant et on va
commencer avec le matin faut je vous
explique c'est simple on est le matin il
ya généralement des enfants du coup moi
j'ai appelé tous les auteurs disponible
de paris une réunion de sept heures
toute la journée on a trouvé matin faux
force est malin ah ouais on regarde
merci
[Musique]
oui attention ce sont les petites
enquêtes à faire fi seulement si je
crois que nous sommes amis et que nous
sommes et devinez qui a passé une grosse
soirée karaoké irc notre jean pierre
elkabbach et ce sont un petit peu la
voix quand même si les républicains
aient débuté et l'air et pendant ce
temps là sur bourde en direct on avait
l'impression d'être au café des sports
beaucoup de vannes trop de vannes il
faut aussi nous disent les spécialistes
ne pas hésiter à nettoyer le chemin du
bonheur c'est à dire la ligne qui
courbent le nombril au bas ventre où la
pomme manière des forts et ce matin
toujours parce qu'elle prouve recevez
les invités les plus francs de la terre
on va pas se mentir
eh ben ils peuvent tenir un grand
électeur vous devez partir ou vous
pouvez rester parce que là faut qu'on
fasse une publicité
et eux yann m'vila il est vous en effet
déjà tard l'ubs à deux mois plus tard
avant d'être adulte mais c'est nommé
dont il jalouse c'est petit bassin sur
vous bouhlal où vous trouverez un bébé
allez allez c'est bon on passe
maintenant au mot du jour vous en avez
forcément entendu parler parce que je
sais que rien ne vous échappe non plus à
vous bande de coquins et le mot du jour
aujourd'hui c'était et c'est aussi le
mouvement des gilets jaune et gilet
jaune gilet jaune du gilet jaune la
colère des gilet jaune le move en gilet
jaune c'est quoi c'est celui des
français en colère contre la hausse du
carburant et on a de plus en plus en
revanche pour être crédible il faudra
dire à ce monsieur de mieux choisir son
chapeau qui roule tous les jours tous
les jours qu'un jour c'est exorbitant et
sur bfm la journaliste h il est
chevalier est parti à la rencontre des
travailleurs français impactés par cette
hausse avec des questions pas hyper
pertinents c'est un véhicule diesel
d'ici le mois de juillet vous pourrez
plus circuler vous pouvez pas vous en
passer de ce camion banon rapport au
fait que c'est son outil de travail vous
en vous en servez comment pourquoi
bah du coup pour le travail sur une
route en tenant le volant quoi mais
heureusement à l'affiner avec un mot
pour le soutenir
il a dû passer une belle journée après
tu vois pas suivre payer les achats les
achats tout ça vous mettra la clé sous
la porte
un mouvement qui fédère les français
mais aussi les politiques qui nous
promettent qu'il n'y a aucune
récupération ya pas de récupération pour
qu'une aimait à tan tan tan tan tan ce
serait pas ta petite tête mon nicolas
dupont aignan 1
pas si ya pas de récupération pour
qu'une grille et nico heureusement un
homme était là pour remonter le niveau
et défendre à bras le corps cette cause
cet homme c'est monsieur jean lassalle
tout gens qui est le seul homme de
france à chauffer sur une statue de
pierre
calme-toi janot pour ça que marianne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très chaud très chaud et le focus d'actu
c'était le documentaire sur jean luc
mélenchon regard sur ces 8 à prêter pmp
donc vers 22h30 et ses revenus du mans
terre dans laquelle on a donc agi là
vers 21h10
merci on a appris beaucoup de choses en
revanche j'espère que jean-luc était pas
de vent assez vite car il a pris un peu
cher ah ouais ça va c'était une énorme
désillusion à 20 heures il prend une
claque qui jean luc mélenchon encaisse
mal l'échec ce communauté française le
rejeter il a mal d'effets comme il
l'était donc c'est une énorme déception
dernier paquet garrido nous a donné un
gros scoop
jean luc mélenchon est un vrai showman
apparemment tremble gad elmaleh il
changea quoi qu'ils ont des histoires
avec la justice a d'ailleurs souvent la
vie capacité de one man show comme à
main et nous a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup fait rire en même temps c'est
vrai que quand on voit jean luc le jeune
il nous fait un peu penser à laspalès de
chevalier laspalès
et du coup on a aussi pu voir
l'évolution des styles de jean-luc il
est passé quand même de jacques mesrine
à cali pas le même délire on a remarqué
que jean-luc avait pas mal de mimiques
et notamment sur un histoire de doigts
jusque de mélenchon et laraque là une
caractéristique majeure celle index sauf
que si on change la musique
son discours est beaucoup moins crédible
[Musique]
je mets le doigt troisième semaine
a priori ces huit avait quelques
problèmes de budget hier ils ont
succombé à la mode du placement de
produit comme avec cette langue qu'on a
vu à peu près 100 92 fois dans le dock
dit avoir vécu lui aussi qu'on la
mettait parfois des retournements de
déchets communautaire nous nous sommes
longuement entreposant le mot alimentent
la colère elle-même vaut d'ailleurs si
vous souhaitez vous la procurer vous
filent un lien direct
ça fait ces huit années qui trouve un
truc qui le met pas tout regardé mais
alors de grâce à deux facteurs
alors je te dis je déteste le prendre
c'est vrai je donne tout et jeudi à
l'antenne des excellents et ben je n'ai
d'ailleurs t'as pas besoin de prompteur
a rétorqué que ce contrat n'est pas un
animateur à prompteur est un animateur
sans talent y en aa par camilla que
camille qui c'est bien ça le plus dur
c'est vrai il ya que camille qui à
l'aise qu'il arrive à le faire et et
sortir le compteur le reste c'est très
dur banal d'ailleurs j'en ai pas ouais
alors animateur mais oui j'ai par les
animateurs non merci à l'essai va
réveiller du coup là on va débriefer
l'aktu qui s'est passé dans le monde
c'est le round 2 ouais mais bon il est
bon pour faire en angleterre un défilé
avec des mannequins la démarche un peu
particulière et nous du coup ça nous a
fait penser à autre chose parce que le
pointu avait dessiné là bas et ouais
c'est les trois favoris hier devant way
et y aura pas de podium pour le 4 x 4
français ensuite aux états unis des
chiens font le buzz dès que donald trump
leur dit de s'asseoir où s'exécute
depuis hier ces chiens sont tout aussi
réactif avec une séquence télé qu'on
commence un peu à connaître
[Musique]
et enfin au canada une image qui fait le
buzz c'est céline dion menotté
une seule aiguille à ok madame peut tout
se permettre sous prétexte d'être une
star internationale
du coup j'ai essayé mais le résultat
n'est pas le même procédé au massage
effet une chronique ascendante et pmp
way essaye de tenir une semaine qu on en
reparle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]